la ville de carcassonne classée
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco la cité
qui compte deux enceintes d'une romaine
et l'autre datant du xiiie siècle
totalise 52 tours et 3 km de remparts
une splendeur architecturale qui fait la
fierté des habitants de la ville
fortifiée léo lamberth ans et demi par
dano quand la brume divers enveloppe la
cité carcassonne ressemble à un vaisseau
fantôme un vaisseau fantôme partie du
lointain moyen-âge et qui auraient
traversé les siècles presque intacte
convaincu du caractère exceptionnel de
la cité le maire de carcassonne se bat
depuis 15 ans pour qu'elle soit inscrite
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
aujourd'hui il savoure sa victoire sans
retenue je voudrais que le monde entier
y les yeux fixés sur notre ville
tellement les belles telmar et les
magnifiques telle marée se dégage est
tellement nous sommes fiers on s'étire
de ce classement
ah je suis fier mais alors vraiment fier
ce qui se dit plus que fier parce que ça
me prenait la tripe province romaine à
part entière qui s'appelait donc bien
entendu la narbonnaise
deux mille cinq cents ans d'histoire ont
façonné la cité forteresse romaine elle
devint au moyen-âge une place forte
entre méditerranée et atlantique avec
ses trois kilomètres de remparts son
château et sa basilique du 11e siècle la
cité classée aux monuments historiques
depuis plus de 100 ans
son inscription au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco est plus une affaire de
prestige que de retombées financières
directes
la france est un pays riche les crédits
de l'unesco vont avant tout aux pays
sous-développés dans le patrimoine
mondial
donc a priori nous n'espérons pas l'état
français continuera à financer les
travaux ici de restauration est mis en
valeur
ce n'est pas une finalité avant tout
financière qui nous a guidés dans la
réalisation de ce dossier de candidature
deux millions de touristes se presti si
chaque année et l'inscription de la cité
au patrimoine mondial rend les
commerçants parce que foriic ça me
convient parfaitement
pas exactement pourquoi parce que parce
que nous serons mondialement connu et
s'amènera en plus à la cité voilà nous
allons pète d'autres touristes d'aider
des pays qui ne venaient pas qu'ils
viendront peut-être nous voir et revoir
notre mail veille à quelques pas de la
cité le canal du midi est lui aussi
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco et carcassonne peut aujourd'hui
s'enorgueillir d'être la seule ville de
france à avoir en son sein deux joyaux
de la planète